la parole est à madame isabelle le
callennec merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à celui qui s'est le
mieux en porte-parole du gouvernement
ministre de l'agriculture et au monsieur
le foll ce n'est pas parce que les
agriculteurs ne manifestent plus pour
l'instant qu'il ne souffre pas ils sont
au travail
mais nombre d'entre eux ne se verse plus
de salaire il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
ils essaient de sauver leur exploitation
quand vous vous êtes au chevet du
président de la république un françois
hollande qui est censé gouverner le pays
agir obtenir des résultats mais ne pense
en réalité qu'à sa réélection l'horizon
des agriculteurs ce n'est pas dans un an
c'est pour certains dans une semaine
pour d'autres à la fin du mois où en
êtes vous du décret sur l'étiquetage
quand allez vous préférez le prêt à taux
zéro plus tôt que l'année blanche
savez vous que la pac 2015 n'est
toujours pas soldé que le fonds de
soutien à la filière porcine n'est
toujours pas en place
quelles initiatives avez vous pris pour
revaloriser le prix du lait depuis le
sommet européen du 4 avril
soutiendrez-vous ce jeudi la résolution
du groupe l'est républicain sur la levée
de l'embargo russe
et puis il ya le traité transatlantique
nous entamons le 13e cycle de
négociations cette semaine la question
de l'alimentation est essentiel et
stratégique nos spécificités
alimentaires sont potentiellement
menacés
je pense à la viande bovine mais aussi
aux aoc et aux aop et au monsieur le
ministre
c'est la question du jour vous avez
déclaré qu'il n'y aura aucun accord
si bien remise en cause des normes
européennes
écoutez moi monsieur le ministre alors
comptez vous enfin déserté la rue de
solférino pour vous consacrer à en
convaincre tous nos partenaires
européens
la parole est à monsieur stéphane le
foll me lisent agriculture
agroalimentaire de la feuille je sais
que chaque jeune ait août à régler ce
type de publicités ciblaient jeu je ne
savais pas que vous me feriez autant de
publicité et en politique j'ai toujours
eu une une règle si on veut être un
adversaire politique
on commence pas par saluer une
initiative de sa politique
donc je vous le dis au passage à
l'aveuglé dette
je vous connais bien vous étiez pas
d'ailleurs à saint malo au déjeuner mais
j'ai bien noté que ce qu'avait dit la
fnsea à ce déjeuner vous a été transmis
puisque j'avais parlé du prêt à taux
zéro et je les dis sur le prêt à taux
zéro sur les questions qui viendront au
delà de du plan de soutien à l'élevage
370 millions d'euros qui ont été le
tueur d'or dans les jours durant aux
éleveurs encore la question est ouverte
et on pourra regarder pour permettre aux
exploitations de faire la soudure
nécessaire lorsqu elles ont besoin pour
mettre en oeuvre leurs exploitations de
près donc sur ce sujet il n'y a aucune
discussion entre nous et au c'était une
précision
ensuite vous avez parlé du la
négociation du traité transatlantique
sur cette question je crois et j'ai vu
que le premier ministre avait lui-même
pris des positions extrêmement clair
comme le président de la république il
ya dans ce débat de la part de la france
des positions qui ont été transmises à
la commission européenne dès la
négociation du mandat de discussion et
sur ces négociations et cette position
de la france sur la question des 10 gp
qui sont la caractéristique de notre
agriculture
il n'y aura aucun droit donné à
la remise en cause 2 et 10 gp sur les
grandes questions de normes sanitaires
ça a été rappelé et ça fera l'objet de
la position réaffirmée de la france si
sur ces questions avec matthias fekl
nous n'obtenons pas les garanties
nécessaires
il n'y aura pas de site de traiter
transatlantique les choses sont claires
les choses sont précises et il ne sert à
rien mr fillon merci monsieur nuit n'a
pas